receipts [ __ ] [ __ ] receipt 99  of the audience had no idea what the  [ __ ] i was talking about earlier in the  week coach sala is why i love the  [ __ ] was like you know what just  sold him you know i'm keeping receipts  i'm keeping the receipts of all of you  that say we suck and we'll never be good  and i understand that like my whole life  everybody thought i was gonna lose d's  and f's so i loved it and then for them  to pull off this miracle nonsensical win  i was so hyped i grabbed the phone  nobody has a clue what it means except  die hard jet bands who's watching a head  coach's tuesday press conference you  have to be the die hard of a die hard of  a die hard and so that's what receipts  meant